okay good day everyone
and welcome to state machine
before we get started just a couple of
uh logistic notes
if you have any question does the q a
panel
from webex or you can drop them into the
slack channel for the conference room
free
or feel free to ping me directly on
slack that's not the problem at all
i'll make i'll do my best to get back to
you as fast as i can after the talk
so
when i was young so it was around
1989. i didn't have a driver license
back then
and i was 16 and
with friends we used to go to milan
to clubs to attend concerts that night
the concert was uh red hot chili peppers
and they weren't that famous yet back
then
and we weren't really interested in the
the band at all so
we were going to this kind of clubs just
because
those clubs back then allowed to do
stage diving
and even if it i still like to go to
concerts
i would love to be able to stage dive
again regardless of this security
problem that is now
my age doesn't really allow that anymore
but anyway so
back to the to the topic here
so if we were to go to a concert today
what we need to do is basically two
things
the first one being buying tickets
so and the second one obviously stage
dive well
go to the consult
from our perspective going to the
concert is basically a
one single operation just buying the
tickets right and then
attend the concert itself but if we try
to look at the concert from the
perspective of
what they want to do so that the company
or the group of people
behind the concert organization what
they have to do
is basically keep calm and make money
that's their main goal right
and in order to do that what they have
to be able to achieve is
first of all they have to be able to
display available tickets
so some sort of website or a phone
you can drop a call to to tell me how
many tickets
you have available and then allow me to
reserve tickets
and once tickets are reserved charge my
credit card
obviously and once the credit card has
been charged and i paid
ship tickets somewhere and
the interesting things of these
operations and many more
obviously because if you think to a
company selling
tickets online they probably sell
gadgets as well and they want to track
marketing related information so what
kind of concerts people look on the
website but they
don't end buying tickets so they want to
track user actions on the website
so one important thing to notice about
these kind of operations is that
sometimes
the order doesn't matter and sometimes
it does
so let me tell you a couple of stories
so a few years ago
i went online to an e-commerce
from a very large and famous device
manufacturer
and i bought device
and that device i put i put it in the
shopping cart
i i did the entire checkout process
and finally i submitted my credit card
and
hit the checkout button and pay button
right
so i received a nice email saying well
your order
is on the way we'll get back to you as
soon as it's shipped
and generally speaking what happens with
this large e-commerce webshop for
example like amazon does
is that your credit card is generally
charged
only when the order is shipped not at
the
exact moment when you buy it but when
they ship
the the stuff to you so in that case
what happened is that
a few days later i received another
email saying
your order is on its way enjoy your
device and
literally a few seconds later a text
message from the credit card company
saying operation denied
so i immediately said well
it's eventual consistency right so the
email went out but they're not really
shipping
anything two days later the shipping
couriers
showed up at my place saying hey here is
your device and meanwhile
for two days the credit card company was
texting me
saying operation denied operation denied
operation denied
so basically what happens is that they
were trying to charge my credit card
but they were constantly failing while
the device was
traveling to my place and
i even called them so i called the
customer support saying hey
i i got this but i haven't paid for it
and the the lady on the phone told me
yeah i know you know i can see that from
my crm thing
i can see that you've got the device and
you haven't paid for it because we
failed in charging your credit card
but you know what from the process that
we have
if it's shipped it's paid so there's
nothing i can do
enjoy your device okay thank you very
much
and that's an interesting point right so
we assume in this case at least that
paying
must happen before shipping is that
always the case not really let's take
for example
highways in italy and i guess the same
happens in
many countries where you pay for
highways
so when you but when you enter a highway
in italy there's a gate
and uh you get a ticket right so
when you exit the highway there's uh you
you can do that talking to a human or to
a machine
you insert the ticket and then you put
in your credit card and the
the gate opens and you just go your
credit card
is not charged synchronously
as you exit the gate so basically what
they are doing is that
they charge your cred they just capture
card information at that time
and the ticket information that you just
put in and they later on try to charge
your credit card
they assume it will work so they're
basically saying
commands won't fail and
other than assuming that it will work
they're basically saying well
usually the amount to be paid is
so small that even if we fail in
charging the credit card it doesn't
really matter
it happens so unfrequently that
missing a couple of customers doesn't
really matter it happened me once
in probably 25 years so the funny thing
is that uh
i was traveling from switzerland back
home to italy and
my credit card was cloned so it was
invalid
and by the time i exited the gate
in the highway what happens is that they
captured information
and later on they tried to charge a
credit card but obviously
the credit card company denied the
transaction because the card was cloned
in the meantime and they never came back
to me
so they're basically the same kind of
thing right
we're paying in both cases for a service
well in the first
case we'll use a device but essentially
we're paying for something
in the first case the order is truly
important from their process perspective
in the second case the order is doesn't
really matter so they prefer to prevent
a possible queue at the gate because if
something goes badly basically you have
cars queuing up at the gate because they
cannot get out
and they prefer to optimize for the
successful case instead of risking of
cars queuing up
so let's go back for a second to our uh
ticket
buying system and let's imagine what
could be a very naive
implementation so the first thing we
said that we need to
show tickets so we can call something
like display available seats
and we get back a list of seats or
tickets whatever they are
and then we say well let's take two so
we we cannot reserve a seat so we just
grabbed two tickets so we have
two selected seats or two selected seats
and then we try to reserve them
so we call the reserve seats and what we
get back is a
reservation that probably contains a
reference to our
tickets and finally well finally along
the process we try to authorize the
credit card
so we authorize the credit card and if
the authorization succeed
then what we try what we do is basically
we charge the card
and finally ship tickets right that's
the process that we described
because we want to make sure that before
we ship
we actually succeed in charging
the credit card the authorization
process is just to make sure that
are there money enough on that credit
card so
one of the the the interesting thing of
this naive
implementation can be as much complex as
you want
right so but it's essentially this kind
of process that you want to design so
one of the problems of this kind of
implementation is that
these are probably remote requests so
we're talking
to sort of payment gateway to authorize
the card
and we're talking again to a sort of
payment greatly to charge the credit
card given the authorization that we
received back
before and we're talking to
probably the shipping courier website or
web api whatever in order to request the
the shipment the pickup of the tickets
that need to be shipped
what's the problem with this kind of
remote requests well the first one is
not very problematic right so if
something
goes badly we just abort the operation
what happens with the second one
so we have we we basically want to
orchestrate in some way
across two operations now
if we have only two operations
what can go badly is that the first one
fails
the charging of the credit card and
we're fine we just
roll back in some way everything and
tell to the user something went badly
just retry whatever you haven't bought
anything your shopping cart is now empty
and we're fine but what happens if the
second one times out
so the bad scenario is exactly that
the http request succeeds
but we don't know because the response
times out the response never come back
so basically we're now in a sort of
unmanageable state because we have no
idea what the scenario is
right so when we when we deal
in such a sequential process with remote
requests
we're always exposed to this kind of
behavior and
the fact that we we really feel the need
of
wrapping this into a sort of transaction
is a sign that something is
is a smell so usually what happens is
that
the first approach to solving this
problem is to
turn this kind of naive implementation
into into into what it's generally
called a process manager
so process managers and i'm i'm using
process managers not necessarily from
the
domain driven design world so so
bear with me and we will see what i mean
by process manager in this case
so there's a kind of overlap with the
ddd but it's not necessarily the domain
driven design
kind of concept so we said that we need
to select tickets
right so the ticket selection process
talks to reservation
in order to select tickets and we have a
request response with
reservations saying hey how many tickets
do you have please reserve me
reserve two for me and then
we have an information that says well
the user wants to check out
i spelled that in a event kind of thing
so order check it out but it's not an
event yet
so we'll get to that later what's the
checkout intent kicks out is the
order management process that's the real
process manager right
so what we do is that we reach out to
the credit card
gateway anti-corruption layer can mean
heavy because it can have many names but
it's basically
a payment gateway that allows us to talk
to the credit card provider
and one of the important thing to notice
is that it's a still request response
but we're doing that using a message
in this case it's exactly a message on a
queue
so we're moving away from remote
requests
as remote procedure calls into a queue
so the reservation one
is a steel might be still a remote
request that
is handled over an lpc kind of approach
but now we're moving to
a remote request over a queue and then
we talk again
to reservation again this in this kind
of
rpc kind of style and then again we go
back to the credit card
saying okay charge the card now so we
authorized it
we confirmed the ticket to reservation
and then we charge the card and finally
we talk to shipping so basically what we
did
is that we isolated remote requests
into its own processes talking to them
through a queue we haven't really
solved the original problem so what
might go wrong is that
let's use the same sample before so we
send out the message to shipping
the shipping gateway the shipping
gateway talks to the shipping courier
api through http again and the response
doesn't come back
what happens is that the process manager
the order manager
never receives a response message
so now the other manager isn't in doubt
anymore
shipping didn't happen so i know what to
do now
i can roll back whatever it means from
this kind of process
the entire process and tell to the user
we failed in shipping
there is no doubt yet so there is no
doubt anymore well there is doubt
but that out is confined into shipping
and
shipping could have said to the
operations team hey
i'm having an issue the opportunity
comes in and
try to fix the issue but from the
process perspective
isolating the doubt into its own
separate process or call it an end point
where we can do just one single
operation
allows us to solve the problem of the
need
of dealing with remote requests
that can fail but
we haven't solved all the problems right
so we still have
some sort of rehearsation is still
required because that
if we if we fail in shipping we need to
roll back the the transaction with the
credit card
so there's this still this chat
happening between credit card and
shipping
but the fact is that orchestration is
not the only issue
we should get rid of let's try to have a
look at the process manager from the
storage perspective so let's imagine
a very simple orders manager where we
have
an order table that contains an order id
a shipping id a shipping status and many
more columns so there will probably be
a payment id and the payment status and
the number of tickets and
so on and so on and so on so now let's
imagine that
someone comes along and says well you
know what
we during the weekend we were
at the golf field playing golf and we
realized that
hi very interesting feature could be
allow people to collect tickets at the
venue
instead of shipping tickets at their
place
so we have a new requirement now that is
collect tickets at the venue
and the problem is that if we look at
this kind of schema
collecting tickets at the venue as an
issue there's no shipping
right so now it means that shipping id
and shipping status
doesn't really represent the
full reality of the system so
one option is that in order to support
this kind of new thing
we have to make shipping id and shipping
status nullable
but that could leads with the fact that
from the high-level perspective of the
code
we cannot really deal with that because
what does it mean
if there's no shipping id so if it is
null
does it mean that there will be no
shipping because
it's collected the venue or because
there hasn't been shipping yet
so we need to change the scheme again
adding a third column
that represents the fact that kind of
shipping
so the shipping type other than the
shipping status and the shipping id
so it's this kind of thing is basically
telling us that the process manager
it's not that different from a punch
card
and when the business come along and say
hey we have a new requirement that new
requirement should go
should go there so basically if
if we picture a process manager like a
punch card what happens is that in order
to fit a new requirement in a very
special place
we have to throw away the entire punch
card there isn't much that you can do
right so we cannot really
put ourselves there and fix a hole in
the punch card to change some numbers
and try to
fit the king requirement in so it's
going to be a mess
not to mention that it's very easy
that if we picture a very complex
process
like buying tickets online could be
because what we
picked are a very it's a very simple
use case so if you picture that real
world process
it's very easy to view a process manager
like this
so what might happen obviously is that
the more featured you add the more the
process manager becomes the big ball of
mud
and it's easy to see what the problem is
right so we have tickets
sitting there in the middle the big bowl
of mud now our tickets
and then we have all the services or all
the actors
trying to do something with tickets like
charging the credit card because tickets
represent an order
and now there's insurance saying i need
to
make sure that these tickets are
delivered and i'm paying an insurance
for these tickets because they are for
the
las cola theater in milan and they are
400 bucks
each ticket right and then we have
marketing trying to do stuff with
tickets and then we have shipping
trying to do stuff with tickets and by
the way there's customer care down there
you can barely see it but well we're
italians right so customer care doesn't
really matter
but anyway so there are all these
services trying to do stuff
with our tickets and
they are fighting with each other that's
why we need an orchestrator
so there's this guy sitting there
looking at all these people
fighting for tickets trying to do stuff
with the tickets
and you can see your code and your
processes and your threads doing stuff
with the tickets
and the orchestrator that acts like a
semaphore or
acts like the distributed transaction
coordinator
in an attempt to make order
in the entropy so there's a lot of cows
going on
and the orchestrator is sitting there
trying to fix stuff and by the way there
are two guys
a lady and the guy sitting over there
back then back there
and who they are a failover
because obviously if you have an
orchestrator and
it fails then you need replacement for
the orchestrator
right so you need to have someone
sitting there doing nothing
just for the problem of the orchestrator
failing
so the both the naive
approach and the process manager
approach even if the process manager
approached by using
messages to the couple some of the
temporal coupling between actors in the
system
they can be seen as fragile first of all
they violate the single responsibility
principle
so in both cases we're doing too many
things
we're reserving tickets we're charging
the user credit card we're shipping
stuff
all in a single place
they're a single unit of deployment so
when someone comes and says
i need a new feature we need to deploy
the entire stuff
so they're in in being monolithic
they cause a problem to the operations
team
because they have to deploy everything
every single time something changes
even if that something is very tiny
if we're dealing with a large code base
and we're using this kind of approaches
then we'll start having conflicting
changes and merge conflicts
because that's a given right if they are
a single unit of deployment probably
they all live in the same
repository and we have multiple teams
touching the same code base
or at least multiple people touching the
same code base
and start changing stuff they should not
really change
and causing problems to other people and
they might be
a contention and performance bottleneck
because it's obvious that
as soon as we have a performance problem
we have to scale up
or scale out everything we cannot really
focus on
what do we need to scale out is the
problem the charging of the credit card
is the problem that hit the tickets the
reservation doesn't really matter right
so we have to scale out everything just
because it's
a single unit of deployment the reality
is that
there's no spoon well there's no process
manager sorry
so what can be
really tricky in this kind of scenarios
is talking to domain experts
so if we start analyzing this kind of
processes
blindly trusting a domain expert
they'll start talking about the order
management system
that's natural because that's the way
they view things
right so and it's super easy
super easy for the engineer that is
always in the back of our mind
that as soon as they say the word
we have an order management system we
picture that as
public class order management system and
they say
we have we can reserve ticket public are
saying
task reserve tickets and things like
that so we
we immediately transition from what they
talk about
to a sort of design and the thing is
that
that leads very easily to a monolithic
kind of thing
because that's the way they describe
things but they're describing
the user mentor model they're describing
the way they picture a user
doing their main process that is selling
tickets
right when we listen to them
we should be carefully listening to the
words the nouns
and the verbs they use and try to
chop it up so what we really want to do
is try to isolate things that should not
stay together
because our our final goal our final
destination in some way
is that we want to have autonomy in
collaborative domains
so we in we
we started all this journey by saying
we have three actions four actions to do
right list tickets
reserve tickets deal with payments
charge the credit card authorize the
credit card ship tickets and finally
stage type that's another problem right
so think about when you
if there's ikea in your country well at
least there is in mind right so
whenever you go to ikea you can you
enter the shop you
you walk around you pick up stuff you
you you make an auto error
in the warehouse stuff that is too big
to be picked up while you're walking the
shop is
and then you reach the cashier you pay
and then it's up to you to decide should
i try to fit
everything in my car oh nice
there's the shipment desk over there let
me go to the shipment desk with my order
and tell them can you ship this stuff at
my place
that's it ikea doesn't really know
anything about that shipping thing
they don't care
and the shipping thing
doesn't really care about what have you
done inside the ikea shop
they just care about the the the list of
things they want
they need to ship and if you have the
list of things
they assume you have paid otherwise you
cannot have the list of things
so it means that they don't care what
happened
at the cashier you might have paid with
a credit card you might have paid with
the
cash you might have paid with a check
whatever
but from their perspective it's not
relevant at all
so the two the two domains we're talking
about
the ikea furniture shop and the shipping
thing that
happens to live inside the same shop
they are completely autonomous from each
other
one is feeding the other so there's a
kind of dependency between the two very
similar to the device
thing we talked before but they are
autonomous that there's a very limited
amount of information that needs to flow
from one domain to the other
if any in order to allow the second one
in this case the shipment
to ship stuff at my place
and if we want to transition that
concept
into architecture we can't really do
using a process manager because if you
think about there isn't
anyone when you're walking inside an
ikea shop
watching over you like like like a kind
of a crawl
that flies over your head and say what
are you doing oh he picked up this
he picked up that let me let me add it
to the to the bill
and while i'm here let me try to charge
their credit card and
see if there's money that doesn't really
happen there isn't
really anyone orchestrating that right
so you're walking into the shop
you you reach the end you're having the
cashier you pay
and technically speaking you're even
allowed to
go away and leave everything there no
one cares right
so when we want to model that as an
architecture concept
we can use sagas so
sagas are designed to
achieve autonomy in collaborative
domains
and let's start by defining what sagas
are
so the the best definition i've found of
sagas is basically sagas are
multiple workflows each one
providing compensating actions for every
step of the workflow
where it can fly where it can fail
let's try to dissect this definition
the first bit is multiple workflows
and you probably already envisioned that
right
so we talked about reserving tickets
we talked about charging credit cards we
talked about
shipping tickets so we can transition
this to
sort of reservation
finance and shipping those are the
free domains or free subdomains or free
services or free microservices call them
as you will doesn't really matter in
this case that we're dealing with
and we if we try to dive in and try to
picture out
what the process could be here is it
could look like so we have available
tickets so
in some way we displayed available
tickets
on the website let's say that as a
website and then we can select tickets
and we select tickets and we do that
using reservation
selecting tickets means that we're going
to put tickets let's say into a shopping
cart
fine then when we're happy with the
ticket selection
then we start checking out at this point
reservation is not really interested
anymore right it's like if we
are at the cashier so we reach the
cashier
and we have some stuff in the shopping
cart and maybe some stuff on a list of
things that
we want to pick up later at warehouse
but we have stuff in the shopping cart
in some way
so what we do is reservation check it
out
because we are at the cashier at this
point the ball
or the hot potatoes goes to the cashier
that
this finance right what finance does is
do something with our credit card and
tell to reservation
you know what the person the payment is
being authorized there's money on the
credit card
and by authorizing the payment we locked
that money
so that money is available to us that's
not
necessarily true but we'll get to that
later
at that point the reservation can say
well i'm happy so
here is the order for you so here is the
the the checkout list
that is the thing that you can later on
use to go to shipping right
so finance says payment succeeded
because we already
locked the money on the credit card and
now that we have these two
information so we have the pickup list
and we have the payment receipt
we can go to shipping or the shipment
desk
at a in the ikea shop and do our stuff
with them
so ship stuff at our place or ship
tickets
in this case if we are still talking
about
delivering tickets so what do we have
here
we have free workflows because you can
imagine that
inside these big boxes there are many
things happening
so they are workflows in some way so
they are state machines the shipping for
example
it's all the finance it's even easier
the payment is being authorized it's the
state where the payment is
and then when it transitions to another
state it's going to be payment
successful
or payment failed because something
might go wrong
shipping as well that's the shipment has
been prepared
the shipping has been delivered the
shipment has been
sent or has been received by the
customer here is the customer signature
and so on
all these workflows they basically
participate
into the tickets ordering saga
so the saga is the relationship
between these workflows right
and to be honest we prefer in particular
software to call them
policies instead of workflows
why because they make sense
from a businessman perspective
so stakeholders they don't understand
the word
workflow so it's much better to
talk about payment policy or shipping
policy
or the reservation policy right so it's
much easier for them to understand what
you're talking about so it's
sharing this kind of common lingo is a
way and is a nice way to
enrich and augment collaboration between
different groups
and for
if any one of you have already been to
an even in
an event storming master class i've done
one with alberto
a couple of years ago you can probably
already see what i'm aiming to that is
these four events reservation check it
out payment authorized
order created payments succeeded are
what the invent storming people
call pivotal events so
a pivotal event is an event that allows
the entire
system in this case the tickets
reservation saga
to transition to a different state
right so if you you probably can imagine
that
inside finance or shipping itself
there's many things happening
so there are many events that are not
relevant at all from the outside
who cares what's important are these
pivotal events
or what in the soa world we call
pub sub events these are the things that
are
cross boundary or cross service
kind of information that flows around
the system
to allow the system to transition from
state a to state b
and state ca maybe back to state b
whatever the process it is
let's now have a look inside the black
box so what's inside these
sagas or what's inside each workflow
let's start again from the available
tickets we go to reservation to select
tickets
we put tickets in the shopping cart and
then we proceed to check out
and we do that again to reservation
reservation publishes the
reservation check it out process that
goes to finance that
initiate the payment process right so
here is the payment workflow starting
and the first step of the payment
workflow is to send out a message to the
payment gateway
that talks to the credit card provider
saying hey can you authorize
this credit card with this amount for me
and if that succeeds there will be a
payment authorized
event that goes back to the observation
that creates the order that publishes
sorry the order created event that again
is interesting for finance might be
interesting for other people as well
like
marketing for example that is
interesting in knowing how many cards
convert into orders
and finance goes back to the payment
gateway saying hey charge this credit
card for me here is the previous
authorization id
you gave me and finally publishes the
payment succeeded
that goes to shipping as the order
created one
and finally shipping talks to the
courier gateway
saying hey can you send me shipping
korea because i need to
send tickets to a customer
is that more complex even the naive
approach
sounds it is right but it's not really
so what we're doing is simply
letting the complexity emerge
we haven't changed the process at all so
the process is exactly the same
process we're trying to design using the
naive approach and the process manager
as well
but now it's clear where the complexity
is
so we we simply let the complexity
emerge
and be clear from the process design
perspective
now let's go back to the requirement
that we got previously
so collect the tickets at the venue
and if we have this nice process where
we have multiple workflows collaborating
with each other
and we we claimed this autonomy in there
right
so collecting ticket collecting tickets
at the venue
is something that should affect
shipping only so that's the only thing
we should be able to change
we have to change in order to allow the
venue collection
let's see if it's possible right so we
said that
shipping in order to be triggered needs
both order created and payment succeeded
what we can do is basically change the
shipping policy
and augment it saying what's the
delivery mode is it
collection at the venue or ship at home
so if it's not collection at the venue
so it's ship at home
we're doing the same process before so
we're sending a message
to the river courier they will come pick
up the tickets and deliver them
we're fine if it is collected the venue
then we're sending a message internally
to shipping
so there's there's another branch
happening here that is
store for venue delivery and what
happens is that
there's another policy that starts that
act
like a kind of a batching a collection
policy
for every event that there will be
so there will be store for the venue
contains
the ticket ids and the event id and
there will be one batch shipping at the
venue policy
for every future event so that ship
that batch shipping policy will collect
tickets
and when it's time they'll deliver them
so
once one of these two operations
happened what we can do is that
we can consider the original shipping
policy
as complete so from the outside
perspective
shipping is done right so if we
immediately shipped going on the right
side so there's no collected the venue
but it's cheap at home
we're fine we're happy it's done tickets
are on their way
if we decided to store for venue
delivery
someone else the big shipping the batch
shipping at the venue policy
have picked up and collected those
tickets well store them
in in in the batch that need to be
shipped in the future so we don't need
any more the original shipping policy
that can be considered
done we can even publish an event like
shipment completed and now we have this
long-living policy that sooner or later
will decide to ship tickets we call a
courier
give them a bachelor of tickets and that
courier will do
they they will do their job and once
they're done they'll reply back saying
we're done tickets are there and then
can kick off for example marketing
saying
we need to send an email to all the
customers that decided to collect
tickets at the venue
in order to let them know how to collect
them
when the on the day of the event will be
and at that point this sub workflow
can be considered completed but from the
outside
who cares right so no one knows that
we changed the entire processing inside
shipping to accommodate
new this new requirement reservation
doesn't care
finance doesn't care at all other parts
of the system might not care at all
right the second bit
of the definition was each one providing
compensating
actions for every step of the workflow
where it can fail
let's see what kind of failures we can
have
let's say that when payment authorized
is raised by
finance reservation fails
and the reservation phase might be a bug
so in processing that message there's a
bug that
makes a reservation go nuts or
reservation is down so it's not
available so it's not really a failure
but no one processes the message
right so what happens is that the order
created
event is never published and
finance never charges the credit card
and the payment succeeded
event is never published and that means
that shipping does nothing
so the interesting thing is the of this
kind of
single responsibility principle
application is that now
a very simple failure in one part of the
system
is fixing stuff for us in some way
because nothing happens there isn't the
need of having an if
somewhere saying as the reservation
failed
oh yes i don't need to ship because the
simple fact that
events are not published make so that
the shipment never happens but we have a
problem
right so we authorize the card
what's the problem with authorizing the
card well it's not really a problem
right
so if you ever been to a note hell
especially in the u.s
for example what they do is that they
authorize your car when you check in
for incidentals so they're basically
saying you're going to stay here a week
here is a thousand bucks charging your
card authorized on your card so that
money is blocked off
you cannot use the card anymore for that
amount of money
and they do they do nothing when you
check out
why because at the end of the month
automatically the credit card
provider will discard authorizations
that haven't been
converted into a payment
right so they don't really care we can
basically do the same thing
so we could say who cares we authorized
the card
nothing happened sooner or later the
authorization will be released
or we can decide to be some sort of a
polite with our customers and try to
compensate the problem
so let's see what we can do the problem
obviously lives in
reservation in finance sorry because we
published
the payment authorized but we never
received
the order created event from reservation
that means that
we have no way to process the second
step that is charging the credit card
the first question and that's a very
interesting temptation is do we need
reservation
to publish a sort of a failed event
and it's very tempting to say yes i'm
very sorry to say that that's coupling
so whenever we ask someone else
outside of our boundaries to change
their processes
in order to accommodate one of our needs
we're basically causing coupling
it's not code coupling it's not binary
coupling in this case
it's a sort of process or business
coupling but it's
still coupling it is so and as we said
before
reservation might be down so if
reservation is
down it won't process the payment
authorized event
and it won't be able to even publish a
reservation failed event
so still we won't receive anything from
reservation what can we do
well there's an interesting thing that
we can do so
whenever we authorize the card if that
authorization succeeds
what we can do is that along with
publishing
the payment authorized event we can
set a timeout in this case i'm saying
set 40 hours 48 hours sorry
time out to release money what's the
timeout
it's a message to ourselves we're
basically asking the system to
hey deliver me back this message
in 48 hours can be 48 seconds can be 48
weeks or whatever whatever the process
dictates right so 48 hours later
what happens is that the message comes
back it reappears
in the queue and what finance can do is
ask itself did i receive the reservation
event
the reservation the order check it out
or the reservation
told me something if the answer is no we
release money
that's it easy peasy if the answer is
yes
we do nothing we don't need to do
anything
why because in the meantime it means
that
reservation came back to us with the
order created event
so finally already the finance already
charged the credit card
published the payment succeeded event
and marked
this process specific to this order as
completed
so the timeout fires and expires for a
process that doesn't exist anymore
so we're happy again right there isn't
really nothing that we need to do
before going ahead let's give a little
dive a little bit sorry
into what a timeout is let's try to
picture that in
in code so we said there's the
reservation checked
out event that is handled by finance and
on on the left side of the screen you
can see the the finance code so what
finance does is
sends out an authorization request that
goes to
the payment gateway the payment gateway
handle
handles the authorization request
authorize the card
talking to the credit card provider and
reply
with the new authorization response
providing the authorization id
assuming that the authorization response
means that it's succeeded
right and we're back to finance
where finance receives the authorization
response
and says well i'm going to publish the
payment authorized event
and the same transaction
i'll get to that in a second i'm going
to request the timeout
for 48 hours so that
someone will get back to me in 48 hours
when the timeout fires then we can
simply check a boolean saying was it
reserved
yes no and do whatever we need to do
based on the process there are a couple
of things i'd like to
highlight here single responsibility
principle
at its maximum so we're sending out a
message
to do one single operation
and if that operation is not
idempotent so we cannot really do let's
say let's imagine that we cannot really
do authorized card
multiple times because the the third
party we're talking to is not that
important
we're going to do this one single
operation only once
and if it fails we do nothing or we can
reply
or publish an event authorization failed
or whatever
and just stop the process and wait for a
human
to come in and probably pick up the
phone and call the credit card provider
hey what happened with this
transaction and secondly
these two operations the publish and the
request timeout are transactional
most of the transports or the queueing
systems
provides a way to have a
sort of transactional dispatch to the
queue because
both the publish and the request timeout
are messages that will be sent to the
queueing system
and the publish is going to behave like
a regular message
that for example on rabbit mq goes to an
exchange and then is
broadcasting to broadcast it to
subscribers
and request timeout it's a delayed
delivery
that goes into the native delayed
delivery infrastructure of rabbi and q
and
is then resurrected into the original
queue
when the timeout expires but they have
to be transactional otherwise with back
to
the problem of what happens if the
publisher succeeds and the
request timeout fails that can be a huge
problem
let's have a look again at the what
happens to the
table schema because we highlighted this
as a problem
right when we were talking about the
process manager
the main difference between using a
from the storage perspective and using
sagas
or multiple workflows
is that we're basically splitting
responsibilities
at the storage as well so we can now
have
each service boundary subdomain
microservice whatever you want to call
them
we can let them have their own storage
that can be even different technologies
i'm picturing stuff here
if they were relational tables but there
is nothing preventing finance to use
mongodb shipping to use sql and
reservation to use
whatever cosmos db on azure doesn't
really matter the only thing they
care about is that they are they are
sharing
the same conceptual primary key
so everyone contains the order id
and his order id primary key that
represent
the order that's coming in from the
checkout request process
is basically shared across all the
services
but the important thing is now that
everyone can avail can evolve
independently
so if we try to fit
the requirement of shipping tickets at
the venue here
we still need a schema change in the
shipping table
but that's not going to be a problem for
anyone else
so we reach autonomous we reach the
autonomy
at all the levels we're basically
cutting the system instead of only
horizontal layers
into vertical layers that's why i like
to call them vertical slices
each slice reservation shipping and
finance
is completely isolated from all the
others
and they are just talking to each other
using
those pivotal events or pub sub events
in order to communicate state changes
to the other actors in the system
so let's recap a little bit uh what
sagas
brings to the table what sagas bring to
the table
the business process is distributed now
so
we have many parties participating into
the business process
as we pictured out we have finance
reservation and shipping
each one of them respecting the single
responsibility principle
and if we want to be even more
prescriptive we could say that inside
each one of them we can have many
workflows now do like we
talked about when we introduced the the
new feature in
the in shipping where we had multiple
workflows again
inside the shipping each one respecting
the single responsibility principle
doing
one single thing the evolution is not
conflicting anymore and it's simpler we
have independent units
of deployment and we have independent
scale out units so that's it that's the
important bits
right what sagas bring to the table
obviously in the interest of time i have
no time to run a demo but there's a demo
available that shows
all this running with multiple processes
starting up
it's built in net core and it's
available
on github here are the links to the demo
and by the way here are the links to the
slides they're already available
and if you wanna hear woody dahan that
is my boss by the way talking about
sagas you can go to that link and there
are a couple of hours of video
woody diving into what sagas are
so let's do a quick recap
pitfalls first because obviously we
don't have silver bullets right
so we've seen that in transitioning from
the naive implementation to the process
manager
to sagas we gain something at every step
and but what's the problem of sagas well
the main issue of sagas
it's so i don't really define that an
issue as an issue but
the most important thing we need to
think about is that
now the state is distributed so we
need to monitor the distributed state
and that might be problematic right
so let's let's try to picture yourself
at the
on the phone with a customer saying
where's my order
and you have to look into multiple
storages
in order to be able to rebuild the order
status
and understand what's the status of the
order whether on the contrary in a
process manager with the single table
and
in the naive approach as well there's
probably a single table where everything
is stored it's super easy to understand
what's the problem right and so
as soon as we started distributing and
trying to fit in autonomy into the
system will obviously get
something back that is all the
advantages that we listed
plus a pitfall in this case that the
fact that
the state is distributed so but what are
the main takeaways
behaviors define how to design processes
not data so
follow the coupling and not the data
listen
to verbs and not to noun
listen to events and not to noun
data are a kind of side effect we need
to store data somewhere
but the thing that is important is which
kind of
processes are touching which kind of
data
so it's the process boundary that
defines
which data should be in those boundaries
and everything else that is not touched
by that process is not needed in there
and once we have identified processes we
can chop them up
and start calling them services
microservices and defining boundaries or
bounded contacts or whatever kind of
architectural approach
style you're using and the second one
is that use delayed messaging to model
time
instead of coming up with batch jobs for
example to
let's let's go let me go through the
entire database of millions of orders
we've received
to see if someone hasn't paid what can
possibly go wrong right
so what we can do is basically for every
transaction like we did for example for
the credit card
we can send ourselves a delayed message
saying hey
check this transaction was it paid yes
otherwise there is money so we can model
every single kind of
this kind of interaction using delayed
messages to make decisions
in a synchronous world in the future
and the last beta is probably the most
important one there is no such thing as
orchestration
and that's really really important most
of the times
there's no need for an orchestrator
there's no need for someone or something
overarching the entire process there's
no need for process manager
we can always model this kind of
relationship between autonomous
components in a system
to model what a business process is
without
any need of building any orchestrator i
i usually tell people whenever you think
to orchestration think to coupling
and coupling is bad right not
necessarily
we can talk about coupling later but
that's not the point of the talk
but it orchestration is not really
needed we can
model every single process
using autonomous components that can
talk to each other
using just events or state changes and
putting
in and setting up compensating actions
in order to overcome two problems that
they might
face while dealing with the process
itself
so my name is mauro servienti i'm a
solution architect at particular
software
we're the makers of a service bus
there's a
few content information you can reach me
too and
thank you very much it was a pleasure
if you have any question obviously i'll
be available
in slack or in the qa
window now i guess for the next
five minutes because then there's the
next speaker coming up
or ping me directory i'll be available
for the next couple of days
i'll be around for the next couple of
days and you can reach to me
even privately on slack no problems we
can even set up a call if you want to
discuss face to face that it's
much better than text thanks again